the uncharted franchise is about many
things but secrets and treasure might be
at the top of that list luckily mr drake
and i go way back and he trusts me with
all his secrets in this video we're
talking about a handful of things you
may not know about the uncharted
franchise for more dude raider content
make sure to subscribe to gamespot
for starters let's talk about the man
that initially inspired nathan drake's
personality and no i'm not talking about
indiana jones even though he did play a
major factor in it as well i'm talking
about johnny knoxville of jackass fame
during a 2015 interview with the verge
naughty dog's josh sheer revealed early
in development there was a version of
nate with a comically emotive face that
was partially based on knoxville the
idea was later scrapped and the team
decided to go the more traditional
handsome lead character out and johnny
if you're watching this they said it not
me you're gorgeous and speaking of
gorgeous men did you know harrison ford
starred in an uncharted commercial if
not that's totally understandable as
they only aired in japan to promote the
release of uncharted 3. in the video
ford can be seen playing the game's
iconic airplane and chateau chapters
while whispering jump and grab it as if
nate can actually hear him something
we're probably all guilty of the whole
thing feels like watching your favorite
grandpa play your ps3 on thanksgiving
the action just keeps on coming
i think it's very
which are very uh
realistic and and
very dramatic
but come on you've gotta admit it's
pretty cool to see indiana jones in
uncharted's world meet for a brief
period
i wonder if harrison ford plans on
seeing the uncharted movie a movie that
once had mark wahlberg as the nathan
drake roll what no this casting took
place in around 2009-2010
when the movie was first trying to get
the ball rolling on production
unfortunately the film changed writers
and directors more than new jersey
changes weather i swear one day i'm
freezing and the next did forget it back
to uncharted eventually marky mark
dropped off the project and the role was
offered to everyone's favorite italian
plumber chris pratt fortunately pratt
turned the role down and even though
nathan fillion expressed interest in his
role as drake in the fan film was
fantastic the role was ultimately given
to peter parker himself in 2017 some
fans thought that phillium was too old
to play drake but now fans believe that
tom is too young to play him hey how old
is jake anyway well i'm glad you asked
devante both amy hennig the game's
writer and nolan north the voice of
drake have revealed in interviews that
nathan is 31 in uncharted one using some
clues from dialogue and assuming the
character's age in real time with each
game release that would make our hero 33
and uncharted 2 35 and uncharted 3 and
the big 4-0 in uc-4 and by the end of
uncharted 4 when we meet cassie who is
around 10 to 14 years old we can assume
nate has crossed into his 50s and is
officially too old for this [ __ ] but
speaking of cassie did you know that she
was named after nate's mother aka her
grandmother cassandra morgan that's
right nate's last name is morgan and
drake is the last name he and brother
sam chose for themselves to honor
cassandra's theory that francis drake
had heirs
you ready for this
hell yeah
and here's one more name fact for you
the drake morgan family dog is named
vicki after victor sullivan and while
some people might feel disrespected to
have a dog named after them sully
actually gave nathan okay during the
hidden and plain sight chapter of
uncharted 4. and speaking of being
hidden in plain sight let's talk about
some easter eggs that were sprinkled
throughout the series for starters in
uncharted 1 the wetsuits that nate and
elena are wearing are from a brand named
otzel this just so happens to be the
same name as daxter's species in jack
and daxter another game from naughty dog
half otter half weasel full auto in fact
a picture of daxter can be seen on the
sleeve of the wetsuit just in case you
needed a little more proof but that's
not the only time naughty dog makes a
reference to their pre-uncharted
releases sully's plane the wild hog is
actually a reference to a leveling crash
bandicoot that shares the same name it's
a level that many fans consider to be
very frustrating over in uncharted 3
naughty dog did the opposite and made a
reference to one of their upcoming games
instead following the fight in the
opening of the game if you head to the
corner of the bar instead of following
sully there is a newspaper that says
scientists are still struggling to
understand deadly fungus this paper was
reportedly meant to be taken out
pre-released as not to spoil the last of
us reveal a month later but clearly it
wasn't a big deal now if the headline
read something like our next game is a
zombie survival game then that might
have been actually worth scrapping the
last of us has some references to
uncharted as well however you'll have to
wait for a things you didn't know about
the last of us video also in uncharted 3
there is a little shout out to a
non-naughty dog game in the form of
little big planet sacboy a key chain of
the character can be seen hanging in the
front of a bus that nate and the gang
make an escape in and that reminds me
have you ever noticed that nate always
manages to make an escape the man is
very lucky so lucky that naughty dog
shows you when he's starting to run out
of luck on screen according to naughty
dog animator jonathan cooper all bullets
flying nate's way are near misses not
hits the player's screen turning red
indicates nate's luck running out he
doesn't actually take bullet damage
until he becomes an unlucky duck and the
enemy gets that one clear shot this is
by far my least favorite uncharted fact
and i laugh every time i think about it
but i think the reason it seems so
strange to me is because so many other
games have gotten me used to the idea
that red screen equals lowered health
from taking damage i can't hate on
naughty dog for trying to be a little
different another fact that you may not
have known is that sam nate's brother
was originally a villain of sorts in
uncharted 4. during an interview amy
hennig the game's former director and
writer explained that the drake brothers
had a different relationship in the
original script hennig said quote i mean
i wouldn't call him the antagonist in
the classic sense but it was an
antagonistic force in drake's life that
he had to reconcile so it was you know
complicated by stuff coming up from the
past so it's a little different than him
showing up and you know hey bro i got a
problem i'm in a lot of trouble here
what
i'm talking about what kind of trouble
hennig also reveals that nadine wasn't
in her original story at all so remember
kids anything is possible nadine went
from not existing to getting her own
spin-off with chloe but did you know
that those adventurous women weren't
naughty dog's first choice sam and sully
were actually first up for the game but
the idea was tossed because of sully's
age at the time uncharted 4 takes place
next in line for consideration was
cassie but the idea was scrapped because
the devs didn't love the idea of a
teenager mass murdering goons thus the
lost legacy we know and love was born
you have a plan
sure
before we close out here's a bonus fact
about nate
his greatest fear
is clowns according to nate those
red-nosed humans are a 10 out of 10 on
his fear scale i've never quite
understood the fear of clowns but my
fear of bugs are like a 9 out of 10 on
my fear of scales so i i'll respect it
and leave clowns out of my uncharted fan
fiction
but alright thanks for watching hit the
like button if you've enjoyed this video
at all and then hit the comment section
and let us know if we missed any facts
see in the next one
[Music]
you